[Music]
I'm gonna start with good news this
space shuttle is going to be driven
through Los Angeles tomorrow isn't that
nice yeah the the bad news it's going to
be driven by Lindsey Lowen her copilot
Amanda Bynes what's going on this very
strange thing is happening in the MIT
Romney campaign a lot of people are
noticing it changing his appearance have
you been reading about this or noticing
it yourself people are commenting that
Mitt Romney has been looking extremely
tan lately got 10 yeah in fact if Romney
gets any darker he's not going to vote
for himself
[Applause]
[Music]
true story though some people are
speculating that Mitt Romney's wearing
self-tanner to pander to Latino voters
that's in the news yeah
even worse he spent all of today driving
through Hispanic neighborhoods with a
Chihuahua strapped to his roof there's a
lowrider and you know more of the video
tape has been released of MIT Romney at
the private fundraiser and there's
actually some today that came out in the
latest tape mit romney implies that
immigrants who come to america have no
skills yeah except of course the one who
knew how to push the record button on
that camera
[Music]
I couldn't believe this monica lewinsky
in the news again monica lewinsky
remember her yeah Monica Lewinsky is
reportedly writing a tell-all about her
affair with Bill Clinton yeah
the book is called ten years too late I
don't I think I think ten might be a
little generous - might be a little more
in three years - Helen oh I mean you
could be even more oh oh yeah we gotta
talk now you can edit this all out no we
can't we can't afford that equipment
what it all has to stay Oh what else is
going maybe we got a Disney World fans
here and if I got news for you a quarter
of you talking about Disney World
[Applause]
I swear to God I heard some boos in
there oh that's the happiest place on
earth
boos Disneyworld
I hate sunshine to Disneyworld just
announced they're gonna plan to start
serving alcohol yeah they're even going
to introduce a new character extremely
Buzz Lightyear
I love you woody
[Music]
New Jersey in the news New Jersey is
banning smiling in driver's license
photos they are that's true so now
instead of telling the driver to say
cheese the DMV photographer will just
say you live in New Jersey
he's mining in Georgia an Applebees
manager called the police on a customer
for breastfeeding her baby yeah yeah the
mothers being charged with serving a
nutritious meal at Applebee's
[Applause]
[Music]
and then I can't believe this happen
again once again in New York a man was
arrested for yelling anti-semitic
remarks while wearing an Elmo costume
folks is it me or is Mel Gibson settling
for lesser roles
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]